one of the first Muslim women to serve
in Congress Democrat Ilhan Omar says she
has faced an increase in death threats
following a controversial tweet by
President Trump president posted the
tweet on Friday declaring we will never
forget the September 11th attacks and
included a video about the congresswoman
some people did something the video
edits comments by the Minnesota
congresswoman interspersed with footage
of 9/11 omar responded in a tweet last
night she accused the president of
encouraging hate speech writing quote we
are all Americans and this is
endangering lives it has to stop it'll
keep us on Capitol Hill with more on
this story ed good morning to you good
morning Gail House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
is asking the US Capitol Police to
conduct a security assessment for
congresswoman Omar the speaker is one of
many Democrats now accusing the
president of trying to incite violence
against the first term lawmaker who
previously has had death threats made
against her the president's not trying
to incite violence against anybody he's
actually speaking out against it White
House press secretary Sarah Sanders
defended the president's tweet on Sunday
saying the congresswoman has a history
of making offensive comments Democrats
refused to call her out for it if she
continues to do it the president will
continue to call her out in a statement
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi demanded the
president take down the video saying
hateful and inflammatory rhetoric
creates real danger and a number of
20:20 Democratic presidential candidates
criticized the president for taking his
attack too far congresswoman Omar was
speaking to the Muslim civil rights
organization care in March when she made
these comments about the World Trade
Center attacks was founded after 9/11
because they recognize that some people
did something and that all of us were
starting to lose access to our civil
liberties Texas Republican congressman
Dan Crenshaw was one of the earliest
critics calling her comments
unbelievable
following outcry from Democrats he
followed up Friday writing when someone
calls out a public official for things
they said it is not endangering their
life or inciting violence
claiming otherwise is just an attempt to
silence your critics congresswoman Omar
has repeatedly faced controversy over
perceived anti-semitic comments in
February she apologized after suggesting
American support for Israel is motivated
by money from the Jewish lobby the
comments were condemned by members of
both parties including speaker Pelosi
and President Trump and a special thanks
to representative Omar of Minnesota
oh oh I forgot
she doesn't like Israel I forgot I'm so
sorry
over the weekend congresswoman Omar
defended herself writing no one person
can threaten my unwavering love for
America earlier this month the
self-proclaimed supporter of the
President was arrested for threatening
to kill the congresswoman we'll see if
the president has anything more to say
about her when he makes an unrelated
visit to her home state of Minnesota
later today John all right ed thank you